alright guys we're back here from the
Last Chance Qualifier slide from the
Second World Tour Finals in Bangkok
Thailand my name is Mark I'm here with
spaghetti rip my god hurry and taste
this Lee a been good so far man we've
seen a lot of character than I've boy
you've seen a lot of different players
Scott's it's getting even better
what's up yeah last year's LCQ winner
man like Peter Landa Lonnie more man
like a land that I'm like okay it's any
man yes The Lost years else key one you
know what cuz no one really thought of
the solid with that known better oh babe
no but no one put it on paper no it's
like it's it's a crazy thing about this
is that anyone on that day could win
this and it was girl on the wolf man
like he's gonna be going up against jet
miss it miss winners quarters so a
little bit into this bracket and he's
sticking with Katarina this is the thing
right so when season three came out he
was deciding should I play stick with
Katarina because she is weaker now but
he was like picking picking Julia it
wasn't working out for him I said to him
look man
Katarina is a character you're most
comfortable with you know the tearless
in this game it's not that important you
can win this no parent has definitely
try and tell people in Sweeney's you
went back to Katarina
a PTC berlin psychic - she came third
you know so Katarina is his strongest
character he's rocking it
let's go round how it is thing
point go Rancho you know went last year
with beer that was that kind of just
proves it right you don't really need
tears it's just like you just if you're
comfortable with the character just rock
on character money to start it off got
Steve's attention that was a big launch
there yeah
I'm in the safe so hey man oh you think
you say what you think you're two people
away you think you're safe all right
never know well Steve starts swinging me
around Giants pick up the table I got a
big 8 85 kilos on me but you didn't see
what happened
[ __ ] squatted my friend kooky by the
way man my brother at all huh Bob see my
brother and on round three I only said
that cause he told me he's supposed to
be here
he told me he was gonna be I'm gonna
come all the way I'm coming there and
I'm telling him going on it was negative
enough where he got that down too but he
wasn't able to combo and look at that no
more meters you always make them out
into the down round out there is when
people go to the skies
the Barry Poppins out of here oh he
doesn't get the stop
the one thing that I saw in Pakistan who
is that sacrifice is there's so many
humans there right against the people
flip a lot of people hooked under it I
don't see that enough people are like
right or to remove little bit yeah brain
go under yet but we have a scene that we
see a lot people try to chop Chinese -
that's dangerous which is the type the
jab and you get a full moon so he had a
matchup college anyway final round here
first good thing too is mitigating the
risk it's hard to do if you don't have
the experience I mean Pakistan one of
those players that has a ton of actually
their defense against that character
should be much better yeah it's not just
about a series but the package how good
you have a head of a wolf is potentially
Oh what did Jeff miss get all those
rounds out of door he was down to around
no bubbles on that side man I didn't see
I'm glad you said that those bad when
you talk about like it's not only about
having access to like all this
information it's about being able to put
in a prac I can know everything in the
book but if I can't do it with my hands
yeah it don't mean squat
doesn't matter don't mean like it man
but if you ain't punishing it well
that's a saturated oh my god he didn't
do it like down for two and then same
combo what's wrong with him I was on
Twitter you're sort of like you're
actually your blank Twitter me you're
playing video game Twitter right now you
can get out well that's what cracks me
up when we go to wear tights
something you have these old dudes with
beards being there what are you doing
come on you need to do you starting well
pretty early but I mean gentleness was
able to come back pretty hard that last
man when he took that music alright you
do the gap oh the wall no luckily I
don't we clean it hurt don't get free
gentleness I round down know where mine
I'm just every time I look up he's got a
bubble that he stole that he stole every
boy left Oh
while sanding to get some demon flip to
follow here you should be able to push
boards along yeah interesting option at
the wall there down once again but ever
the corner dangerous are you doing you
work for the one looks like the wall
break is that we'll use gold for all
he's done he's like look crouching 3kp
we're down to immediately to start the
round hag jet miss looking really strong
to put the last year's LCQ winner
introduces rock in early on
anyway all very dangerous big break each
other that's a classic to stay what
right got into one one two right yeah
here all he could have killed right
there but doesn't matter right now in
rage Carolina it's all on him all on him
he's gonna have another cinderella story
a vote of a day we're gonna find out no
you still the losers you can't count him
out
it's true it's true you can't count
about
out of nowhere mixer mouth yeah
miss from the Philippines ripping the
Philippines man we've been talking we've
gotten a lot of chances to talk about
the Philippines just how strongly every
territory in all honesty has been
represented here has been doing pretty
pretty bad I mean quit the LCQ what more
can you back we are asking for more
matches and we're gonna get them here we
go it is what we got knighting spirit
aka that boy from Korea with a nasty
look I'm watching he's one of the people
on watch scream a lot have a fighting
spirit one of those guys very very
strong at speed there's nothing to see
this for sure my wonders top top players
in Korea you've got America on another
side from Belgium in the pod that TVB
crew is the follow-up here has another
opportunities you have to be careful
nice low parry just do crazy crazy hair
you got a nice range of colors on his
arcade stick man that light is doing
some trippy that shirt is definitely not
that color right now it's like orange or
something no I'm pretty sure it's it's
infrared is that infrared color
don't this song again
[Music]
all about balance man all right here we
go match number two and it looks like
again fighting spirits should be up 1-0
at this point all right yeah a lot of
people didn't know that he was coming
out here man fighting spirit a lot of us
didn't know because he didn't sign up
under his master DG name so we had to
make adjustment at the last minute that
thing was hard
yes make sure you guys sign up with your
actual player please please Rick has a
lot of stuff to worry about already so
good use one account you know actually
uh one of the guys while ago I'm in
great shape fine spirit fighting spirit
definitely like the clothes
because I think it's neutral on block so
I put you back in for that situation but
a nice fight for his defense holding up
you always gotta watch out for that back
one you know
noctus doesn't have a lot of moves that
without a high crush the best lows back
one back to up close all really good
tools yeah I mean the best - awesome
excuse me Oh set point now for fighting
spirit of a medical route trade wasn't
able to get the full combo like this oh
he liquor cancel one that's pretty hard
to do man
like sometimes read moved around the
money knew exactly what to do fine
smooth looking very comfortable
moves on here please like a place
playing Steve like a real boxing like
yeah the boyfriend is too from Belgium
yeah I met him earlier yeah yeah yeah oh
this is gonna make it oh we got a liquid
again from Japan regular he goes and he
plays at fighting Tuesday quite regular
he he actually works at Red Bull uh game
experience ochio so I know he works at
so so a battle between East and West
Japan then even in Japan man I noticed
they've been trying to hold more offline
events like the fighting Tuesday's a big
Tuesday is actually ridiculous like I've
been there multiple times it's good how
was the in Japan them dude is there a
rivalry difference in general there was
like when you'd see this ambassador Cup
especially in Marcos
east-west Japan so you got mainly all
something so bill yeah of course no the
farther down to shew in those areas are
pretty strong they started really coming
at the promised I think during the tech
two days is really where Kyushu started
their rise with you know players like
again like no Roma yeah yeah typically
for the longest time
so again and Thai say those someone so
meet I say was like someone who taught
in after date second and they for the
same area immediately
[Music]
no no he's from few foods oh then you're
right then the skins from there as well
start he wasn't it was evil and he got
second place or third place second
second second second when he was 14 it's
crazy yeah
that's what JD Shaw was like unbeatable
you know that was a very good a very
good first tickle player picked up by
liquid cuz he was young and his dad was
taken to all the way to my dad kind of
like a kind of make he actually started
around the same time cool cuz I mean
it's not a K at the whole camp
he was also 14 years old
now the one in Tokyo right not the one I
thought that was a 2015 no it was - but
you stole it's those kids that come from
the arcade they they're a different
breed you know I mean like yeah and I
was in Korea recently man and you know
Korea thing there's no one I hated even
round everyone just play online and I'm
like every one of Korea's kind of scared
that they're not gonna have a generation
of pretty strong players read in the
carcase yeah that's true that's true
I've heard that exactly especially don't
get like that was a very important
structure late I mean it's all about
unity I mean you think about it there's
other places around the world that don't
have the infrastructure to have green
online play particularly Pakistan they
still crack out on sessions like crazy
I'm personally like I would rather play
in person and I can run the city that's
why when Pakistan when they pray like a
firsta 20 in the first 30 I'm like this
will be did back and say we were going
to basement it just played 30 40 games
one person and that's how you get that
person that's my personal thing it shows
showing you the results man
back row you got the bomb should we
leave right now book the tickets
Murray book the tickets take the Mishima
jet let's go
I think if you guys want me around here
for tomorrow maybe tell machine when I
first saw the customization but you know
that was one of things to stuck out I
don't know if you guys remember he was
tagged to we had a event where all of
the press from Europe went to Dubai and
we did all kinds of cool [ __ ] like they
took everyone out of four by fours into
the desert safari yeah and then they
were doing the Falcon in out there and
it was so tight yeah how are you
controlling I would agree we had dinner
out yeah this is a fiery man is so
slight so good
we've got a really good yes you can
bring it back though so yeah like I was
saying you guys know fine a Tuesday but
now there's a G and a few of the other
players are trying to create or like
bolster its it was a whole new people so
go to arcades in Japan I heard it they
still they still people there's still
people play even when I was there we go
the exact same thing goes to the arcade
and just run nothing but online take a
match even these outdated
that's definitely or yeah see right now
you know kittens really been showing his
dominance into the village of the magic
at least yeah I mean Shaheen just really
show how Great America is here
yeah so he pays a three man [ __ ] dad
okay no hi it's like a martial arts
movie and I love it every second of
backflip out of the low excellent use of
the reverse temple step in that round
able to get two huge hits early on yeah
with the ground event we'll see if he's
able to tie it up wow what a read on the
low out of factor
my far too simple once again and save
him quite a few times at the moment
[Music]
again now on setpoint hair putting Ishii
into losses and move on to win its
finals told you man oh no double
scorpion that's pretty bad you got to be
careful double scorpion what does that
colony but anyway they're Japanese they
called okie not okay break his leg I'm
desperate yeah okay that's interesting
we have to start using our combat remark
he was up okay why's it landing on the
dimmers on the ground yeah
Oh Perry yo selfie black Chevy Germany
ah the woman oh you you is actually
switching to link so she probably lost
that first match with the Safina I also
feel black are you ready
if you have to place use Athena he goes
obviously he was because she is now
using it must have been a blow up
brother it must have been a flow up if
you switch to show you because I haven't
seen a while with rage it's hard
you looking to tie it up here though I
love about something black as well he
never switched from the girl now
when everyone is saying you've got t-rex
arms and I love that more I'm telling
you character loyalist those are the
people I trust the most right now
anybody what's he using him in the
tattoo though yes Jenna go Ginny Miguel
that's a tasty Steve T that is
definitely my pain they had the special
throw or the tag but all it was so sick
oh did that book I don't think it's
discount ok slivers no he's gonna do it
it looks like he reaches in his pocket
when he does like yeah yeah my favorite
I know that's why I was there follow-up
selfie so patiently he'll wait for the
bus all day okay oh except for that time
wait a minute sir
but you know it's cool man I've been in
Japan since maybe 96 right they used to
dress like that long shirt you mean you
used to dress like yours well maybe
maybe but but no that was like the
fashion and Yamazaki that's like the
some of the bad dudes yeah they actually
dress like that so you could see like
shot into that time you know of Japan
what they had at ER for like the
deliverance of the gangsters the posters
over the the biker gang guys yeah the
bus look for the bikers these were
champio which is kind of like almost
borderline Yakuza whoa Junior yup you
know I bought the hints oh I had some
green listen to this I had green photos
and that turn that puts themselves in
the bag I just kept it attached at the
leg like II already I'm not even joking
that's not an exaggeration
those times as a parent crazy we're
gonna bring it back hey I'm down look
give me those pants we here
I got gi's pants I got it all out I'm
telling you you got him in the house
really came over rinsed came to my house
and I had like harem pants with Dragons
on he's like yo Steve I was like I'll
give you that that's how real I am about
it but here we go
my dude you don't live in Japan
obviously not a master closet versus
America here this is gonna make it much
costume here's the thing for a very very
long time in the arcades you know he was
one of the guys that brought us in back
into the game back second-party told me
that Gossett beat him so bad in the
arcade and instead you know what I'm
gonna get good at this game and he
tossed him so possible the guy you know
he's been running it for a long time in
Pakistan but his corner performances
haven't quite been there to show how
good yeah his dad at work cut out for
this is an opportunity
wasn't he one of the guys doing the
first attempt
yeah it wasn't pretty don't be she bad
to be fair need beat almost everybody
there yeah three people winded up
winning and there were a lot of close
matches since that's but yeah II mean II
just really showing how he's one of the
world wasn't surprising to me me right
now he's thing gonna on a different
level you know he's deaf people down
much up he's comfortable in season 3 now
p.m. right Ryan again and being much
more aggressive the Brian against the
crew bob is the path I was dead when he
figured out this is the motto it's
really good oh man that's the tech Marie
that's the tech Boston will be used to
the matchup they have a lot of
Oh other side
probably what he wanted he try to go for
a carry right there I didn't work yeah
almost got clipped with the tracking
move 29 seconds left on the clock yeah
well hey we'll do it what a plot they
seen that before
I love that
Steve's rays drive when something
happens my shadow could keep the
coaching thing is about it like these
guys hang out a lot and every event you
can see them kind of like you know
hanging out together and they try and of
course the talk is taking off they want
to be able to discuss matchups like well
look any better they shadow users the
females I mean probably giving some
machop advice here know what to do what
to wear to step all the kind of stuff
cost him 100 up looking very comfortable
in this man I haven't fought too many is
a penis but I went to wins and I fights
and I fought my K he did they do like
the weekly stance when they want to
learn new characters and like I feel
like legacy is so strong in his game
like cuz a lot of my knowledge came from
just fighting like uncountables and like
the FINA yeah but even still she feel so
strong of a character now and my
competing in the game very well
especially taking 7 I really like our
addition to the game also when you have
one to take into account like power
crush as well you know she has boobs
from stars in our critique on China
I used to be able to talk to you a lot
to learn to try to learn the matchup has
a huge second set up now right so many
things that you have to look out for
just look at Twitter you hear you see
them all day they're like may not even
even deal with his curtain nothing makes
it she crawls on the ground what is
going on micro thank you about five
years too late and you brought that up
spag that's why we don't have like can't
imagine that I'm straight off the bat
overwhelming it's the man I've taken
seven lakhs of this roster Oh crying all
day
even there the one lights lights if
they're off trucky yeah I'm gonna do
that before bed the shadows off as well
he was already now once again set point
now I just witnessed finals you went for
it again any adjustment the combo as
well boy definitely looking to troubled
now is gonna be it can you find the wall
oh you got it six round straight they're
costing me looking really really solid
at the moment
Trumpy though not over yet he's gonna be
the loser bracket costed me it out Micah
Sonic you strung that yeah of course
Pakistan looking strong oh yeah I made
it to beat Histories
and it's a picture of the top eight from
Edo Japan and like when I took that
photo ID news this year in Tekken was
gonna be ridiculous that was between I
was like bro there's no way Tech is not
gonna be the dick oh yeah because that's
a diverse 16 countries in the top eight
it was it was insane and there was no
Korean or Japanese to grab by now
I remember last year when everyone was
like nari we got two friends without
Japan and then US and Europe is like oh
we're gonna do no I don't hear that so
animated Oh enemy guy look what I'm
grabbing my oh I'm not even joking I'm
grabbing my arm to stop and grabbing
that reason it didn't work out true
brutal song and right now we have two
great players from the Philippines we
have coffee Prince what are the top
Steve players out of the flippin going
up against jet Mishima who has turn to
the dark side here kuma but did you see
that you see how you walked under the
air something we don't see that often
but this guy clearly knows matter does
it matter if you do the matchup against
Cuba what you get to get down through
there with that put them in right well
that was sick
what does the voice actors name again
the guy that you yelled in whatever
whatever do it they were doing the
presentation that guy the voice actor
for Akuma do you know him you worked
with them right it was the last goodbye
infraspinous de prague his arms you know
Steve outloud said were you serious like
it was over it was so audible because it
was quiet in the room I was like are you
serious you could tell because you just
heard what was in your head man so many
great moments in like tekken 7 it's been
it's been like spectacular every year it
just gets better and better you're just
talking about this yeah man the move are
the matchup we talked about yeah so the
reason why wouldn't need me explained it
to me he said look if you can't wit
punish down to what you need to do is
you need to preemptively use a move to
try and counter here and the best move
the Brian has to do to keep him out is
previous war and you can get counting
it's very easily if they try to use down
to from a range right so deep is Paul is
very good also when Brian gets to
Akuma's back it gets damaged and if you
block down for sweet the wall something
too it's a huge huge nother combo so if
Brian is oh yeah we get a whole
fisherman combo off that would have been
a yeah Andy been prepared that's the
thing is like you have to be prepared in
negative portion situations do the Jenna
yeah just like walking to do it i bribe
isn't that kind of character mine like
you can't just pick him up no way you
know he's another one of those
characters you can't be like you I'm
gonna start taking a plain brown bro
hold on wait a minute wait a minute
not the way it works
oh wow crazy-cool yeah bet he's on that
fun I didn't know he was that aggressive
my man is partying right now give me
some hors d'oeuvres of this bad boy to
pay to get it out unfortunate there he
went for the ground to hit unable to get
in there and look at that jet machine
the one round away from moving on mr.
Cooper's really impressive mode
you got it also from the Philippines
maybe there you see each other
shut off the secret base to one of the
names I got familiar with from the
Philippines as well without that how's
that
super super couple one of those players
actually made the hooker [ __ ] out to
the Pakistan to the Italian gym playing
it's a lot of place you went over to
talker couple yeah it wasn't nice but he
got he got to make speedo I'm gonna tell
you that right now
like I was like I know people don't
think I'm like yo man that got tough I
know what it's like to go to another
country and get worked I know I know
that feeling
so it takes a lot to actually do that
like Michael Moore you're right like
it's not easy to go to another country
be like you know what I want to come
here cool experience
it's a part of the process he said to me
look I'm not going there expecting to
win I'm going there to get my ass kicked
I want to go there and that's the best
way to learn so he has a very good
attitude that was cool though man I mean
I met him in one championship it got
taught him quite a bit yeah it was right
at the peak with everyone's hating on
Akuma yeah and I was like dude
definitely told it like it was like
people don't know how to fight against
them yeah yeah most people are the
people I guess the regions that would
complain about them don't know how to
fight against kagemaru oh let's go this
could be like my arm could be in danger
yah yah keymod was one of those guys
that has been putting up hype stuff some
hype stuff we're seeing lay now as well
about cards we see often the sperm used
to play don't hear a whole lot
yeah so maybe kog'maw should know the
matchup if he does Megan's able to get
them back to follow up that's natural
combo as well let me go only drop the
board neutral - it doesn't matter has
another opportunity with the stands
transition okay picks up with you guys
he's out taking that first round here
one of the characters we were talking
about earlier been really loved how
these guys play like yeah
oh he was I still think that's one of
the greatest eSports quotation mark
eSports comebacks of all time Rachel on
the talk' oh so good I remember yes
Steve Stevens you gonna had to soak up
real quick yeah what's going on here you
know what I was pretty far what my
favorite players was actually taught me
Saki Saki the legendary arcade warrior
he has like the most gameplay wins on
his car
and you could tell keys he always had
that iron helmet that was like his
trademark for the trophy
she rounds up here nice and early
looking good talking about trying to
find his way and shut off the porkchop
man he's been helping like off all for
eSports in Atlanta if the things got it
yeah the SPO dated what is the [ __ ]
Atlanta battle off yeah recently he's
been helping out with that but he
definitely a place he actually stopped
he stopped everybody from Korea from
winning their local he's the one that
was so good able to catch him out of
there you should be able to put towards
the wall what does he got rage [ __ ]
interrupts him hi okay wait a minute
pocket model getting something started
that round we know that's another cool
thing wasn't or now that everyone even
outside of Tekken is watching it you see
the characters like poke top that we
love everyone are just fighting it now
oh my god oh they're talking [ __ ] you
know I saw you know who would a soccer
goal make a coma was there he was
wearing a no round brown shirt when I
walked up that we walked up to me
wearing a no around browser me too man
like it's like I'm gonna pork chop the
so long for so long and like it's really
cool that people get that you know
person down he's one of the reasons I
fell in love with taken and traveling in
wing what cuz of people at work
especially like just Atlanta in June
it's interesting though as much as he
doesn't cuss right no he'd never curse
there because he's a family he's a super
family man he don't drop no bad words at
all he's gotta make it a kids look at
him just pop it off but it's like a
chibi version him I want my rights about
for that by the way I know you're gonna
do it
impressive work here from Guevara able
to take it oh my gosh this match with
Mooney Dan goodie not from Japan from
fronts yeah but look at that CUDA has
lead right now he's gonna get the desk
Garrity - against the wall here we need
such a such a solitary defense on point
but he's going up against Sudan man well
best thing you know hoodies been able to
beat a lot of great players in here I
remember he was able to beat Jimmy J
Tran and tournament before yes you speed
so many players speed kicks wants
pancakes yeah those speakers always run
back but still you know race on it
rage available don't do the dog to the
racer I know you want to do it back -
good punish three around straight we're
back in here oh my gosh back-to-back
matching with us on Ali again it gets
talked about rocket motors up 1-0 right
now yes the three round comeback made
the reverse sweep in that last match the
CPS I can bring it back is the winners
finals so much a play for the patient
Amaro
like you have to be that way first play
I either was happy we gotta watch what
he's doing yeah
that changed too with for Wallsend III
doing that weird kind of like stun where
they fall great mix up since she has
that back I'm lucky miss from Kharkov
are like I said we're fighting late no
matter what you still have to make sure
what he's doing is possibly punished
he's one of those parents you got to pay
attention to you trying to get him to
kind of chase him down they have the
live feed
be careful vote look at that looking
really good talk about a really keen
control of the match yeah Porter she got
oh did not expect that overwhelming him
right now kagemaru two rounds up set
point now to put s and introduces get
out of pools very important winners
final towards the wall he's gonna get it
the research is about fourth one to
straight into the hood no one really
but it's so accepted for this quick are
other people are used to it people are
just used to respect to the downfall of
lunch it'll get already forever and I
guess how Gabbar doesn't really need to
use that to mommy's different struggle
Nelson her down you know it's pretty
decent almighty soldier yeah she could
be guru Crouch now which is crazy
yeah and he is crazy oh but not as crazy
as this gets the hit and the follow up
their two routes to one
she's so I was waiting for you to say
something bad about why I like that
letter recovery to God let's go please
keeping him there he won't break into it
oh that was sick that was actually sick
come on
oh yeah kog'maw rockin with the my feet
now chillin st. patiently picture shots
oh yeah positions as well and step last
chance an opportunity nice conversion
the combo make this is big
what's gonna do with it look at that in
the pressure range available now this is
one more mix up your equipment last time
oh my gosh liver takes it yes exactly
what you think about Michael just using
that standing through you keep it around
right yeah a really good thing you saw
there just seen with that down for at
for right a lot of times didn't do that
in purpose and then when they get up hit
him with a three they have counter hits
right into another combo yeah yeah
because they think they can press upon
its that yeah yeah oh here we go back to
Cooney versus put on scoop previously
croutons was up 1-0 he had three
straight rounds well that seems able to
extend it here it has follow-up set
really simple playstyle Kony has just a
lot of standing two tries to keep his
opponent out this is actually uh I think
like a good conditioning match
especially for Mishima's I mean you
gotta really test yourself against Jack
make sure your slice of not make sure
your little actions are on point how are
you saying a lot cuz up board for
doesn't get guaranteed back for anymore
I would have been a
you know right nerves I like what you
like I like that there you go Murray let
him know like everybody is hard okay
feel like bitching all the time but I'm
like okay require right here looking a
lot better for Gunny like he was saying
yeah one of the things that you and her
I devote said a while back I think it
maybe was very to tag two days when
someone was talking about how the
machine was were so strong and then the
response was there supposed to be sure I
don't think that's the best response
that is the best response
oh nice able to get the godfist ball
over here you get the wallet that match
that's gonna hurt that's gonna hurt yeah
there you go
demon pie look at that one more round
kudos we're gonna take it here and move
on this is the winners final four b2 as
well yeah oh wow oh not arranged a what
I can't believe the hit oh say big body
big body body kunai's walking by you got
a big smile on his face
they dude always makes me happy oh here
we go in the follow-up
Oh for the layout of rates a nice bait
look at that you should be able to close
it out yep very very solid stuff
definitely you dance foot good knee into
losers moves out of the pool in winners
very brave oh I can't wait to see this
oh my gosh
Bilal from Pakistan versus a cane the
penis of Pakistan yeah so probably the
one of the best prime players out of
Pakistan right yes but you know who he's
using for he ain't using O'Brien he's
not used to Bryan it in TW t so far when
he was I believe Malaysia he was using
Akuma in that tournament right yeah yeah
of course
and he we were in the Jordan
Invitational to face my esports they got
these guys had an invitational with the
Hawks ruggedized in the round-robin he
caught eight wins and 100 really that
was blinder well I missed a whopping
their protocol versus a cool no way tell
you right now kak looked back he was
like huh oh cool no they since the way
mark said that they all today all do now
they just they've kept them out of out
of public view I don't know if it's a
good time to find out right now how this
is gonna change up because we know that
Bello has been using Akuma throughout
the tour line but now a K first time
we're seeing a musical while punishing
the gate blocks down
Philippines what's at the dark side - I
mean we can't do anything from over here
they can't hear us not someone to bring
that up right
thank you Michael Marie got paying
attention it doesn't matter has another
opportunity you looked at he's building
up this meter as well
goes for the wall standing - not looking
good for a key but he does have rage
that's the thing the big difference here
Wow like I dashed up into lo Perry the
confidence levels here from Villa is
through the roof right now yeah he's
like he's ready all the time okay
dangerous dog could be put below with
chief on the phone by the wall to
quickly get out of there and turn the
actually kind of scared and I feel like
he's warming up to that point
wait a minute now that I think about
this the wall major saw was a blur - oh
my god what's going on oh good rage
available for bilal and a barometer has
resources 15 second up the top
okay with the leader he's contending
just chillin yeah all this big that
might be that should be there just in
time we got to remind them not to make
the same outfit
you might just switch cards ahem oh yeah
you went to state select ready wait wait
wait we might want to get them a stuff
yeah that's what it co is that yeah
gives up another production team letter
no they can't pick the same costume yeah
definitely not then work out the perfect
way right however we saw like the
beginnings we saw what I mean like a K
is that kind of player where he plays he
has a little disrespect to his
playwright and I feel like him having a
pocket of kuma is a serious game well
the fact he didn't change character
means he came in with a game plan yeah
stick to that game as well even if it
didn't work out from him his first match
let's see if you can execute his plan
here this is what he was training for
obviously looking for this opportunity
he knew someone from Pakistan and he
anyways yeah knowing that they're
probably well versed yeah defensively
against his character doesn't matter if
he's fighting against another whom oh
yeah either way let's see how this works
out
punished
Tech's propose you to sit a little bit
of twang in it I'm telling you right now
it's scary he's making Akuma
wait a minute but you made the biggest
meter right you know that hits me every
day like every time I'm on the stage I'm
like dude I'm playing chicken in the key
steve is playing it's ridiculous
oh wait till we get downstairs we look
at the flower right okay should be able
to boil here let see what he doesn't
like it that was it's completely
different okey option now I've ever seen
and it's possibly just a drop and this
one thing to it he controls the range
afterwards on no keyword he knows that
he'll be able to purple there he goes
from the down free options follow along
has the meter let's see what he doesn't
it goes for the same mix up the a key
one for earlier Oh the tracking yeah
good call mom allows that point right
this is a big to cousin aka wrist
obviously he needs this round but he's
starting to make some adjustments he had
started playing and looking much better
with a cumin here in match number two
someone hit that down three key know
that down to what's it gonna be both
have the ability he went with the reset
what's he doing boyfriend demon flip a
good thing there it is that could be all
the difference because what metres
enough to get up to the wall and that's
the tick he needs to get to the wall you
need to start asserting their dominance
here in the matchup when it's gonna be
hard to get that initial in oh oh he had
the biggity confirm confirm I didn't
believe
again always got a church those
fireballs this is anyone's game this is
anyone's game right now
Oh
what is going on he has the wall who's
coming it drops it is this time there's
no time
what's that games there's no time he
wouldn't even it would have been no no
was I might have not looking for the
side wall I think my it worked hard
enough someone drops it yes true doesn't
matter anyway it don't even matter it
don't even matter we're still here but
law choked him and he had two
opportunities to use the fireball and
get a full combo he didn't believe in a
man didn't do it anyway moving on to
next my arm Joe no Joey no
mr. Red Bull athlete strolling through
here right I know right they switch with
the double Shaheed double Akuma what's
going on yeah we switched in between
this is the final match between again
and this is again winners mine oh wow
Philippines Russia Japan right when the
Peters representing hot mom yeah okay
having eleven guys here out out here
representing woo oh what a truck yeah in
the food year that's the house party she
pajama Jam come on
break his legs
break his legs ha ha with the life leave
Oh Eddie get to this big should be the
round one round away progressing through
win is when we wha wha that's why I love
this see you guys keep talking like
we're hanging out you do the drums I'll
do the guitar qualifying out on the
winners side here pull b12 I believe
we're gonna go wait till he's up the
longer than ek is playing I told you he
was like he go you said if Ronan chimed
Pakistan Takuma have you seen the
Philippine ok please the waiting it's
scary I'm like a cool kid do what they
please how it was not just the respect
of Akuma matters on how how bad you
ditched your meter yeah that is the
strength of a when you go into that dark
contract with that character sending me
sodas yeah it depends on how expensive
your soul was and up until this point we
saw a cane only using Shaheen that's
higher year right yeah that's an
expensive soul
Oh ghost oh my gosh punished right now
he was really greedy without he was
really with that low yes he didn't
believe in himself again he had the
standing to he could have he's choking
it mom he's choking just salesmen have
come away never know wait a minute
another one another one use this meter
that's even more brutal
cuz there's still two more rounds for
each player to win time's wasting once
he caught him in there just oh this is
tough it's not gonna kill good what
could happen though he's gonna be in
only 30 seconds oh okay does the lead oh
my god hello here we go crazy oh man
there's too many Akuma players near me
Trixie just showed up I looked at it be
careful there's too many of whom is here
oh you try to fish for the downpour to
lunch wasn't able to get there unless
I've kicked my momentum on the long side
but I bar me to play Kay oh you wouldn't
be standing too nice down for the
downpour starting to come out oh yeah
covered enough ground there with the 442
and this is not looking good for hey Kay
that last little that last three seconds
of that round yeah he believes in
himself that time but Manville I'll able
to take a cake go into the loser's
bracket now he's gonna have to win a few
more sets of matches if he wants to get
out
three seconds of that round does that
match the round before that was insane
that trade his police pal is so well
suited for character like Akuma
he can do things for people just
naturally afraid of it and his wif
punishment is really good
he was standing there's so many times
where he was just like I'm not gonna
move I love that oh man Gracie so many
good matches so many more to go and this
is only the LCQ tell me that we've been
to that we any of us have seen from
Tekken that has not been nail-biting
exciting every single one over the past
few years has delivered in ways that
made us too tired to do commentary the
next day that is facts I remember when
we actually had to do an LCQ it was a
LCQ for us too we were commentating so
many matches it was like 10 Elsie Hughes
in one day it was ridiculous lost every
single yeah his soul is still in that
bill physically but his body is still in
San Francisco right now his soul still
just floating above the setup alright
Michael is there anything you want to
tell the Tekken fans that are watching
at home we're about to take a quick
break but I think you're gonna be done
with commentary for the day yeah man
that's just a start it's what 4 p.m.
here we've still got many hours up to
Tekken and this is just the first day we
got whoever wins this is gonna be in for
the finals tomorrow we're gonna we have
a full stack commentator desk for
tomorrow as well and I'll be talking to
you guys tomorrow sometimes it was yes
so guys we will be back with more from
the LCQ here live from Bangkok Thailand
just after this see you guys